hi I'm Erik Bosse in the new movie baby
driver is one of the most thrilling and
entertaining films I've ever seen
director Edgar Wright who also made shot
of a dead and Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world is one of my favorite filmmakers
his whole visual style and the way he
has been increasingly studying his films
music with choreographed action scenes
that play out like music videos now with
baby driver Wright takes this method to
a whole new level writing the full 35
song soundtrack into the script and
letting each song dictate the narrative
of the scene medicine now this is the
opposite of how music normally works in
films traditionally scenes are written
and shot and edited and then a composer
composes the score to the scene he said
he was actually warned by director
Quentin Tarantino not to write the exact
songs into the script before shooting
because often it's hard for the studio
to secure the right to use these songs
but Wright did it anyway and he blasted
this music over speakers on set and had
actors and crew people listen to
synchronized hype on and the end result
is that it all plays out like an action
musical like stomp but with cars
honestly it feels a lot more like after
you see a Fast and Furious movie and
you're driving home and some great song
comes over the radio and then suddenly
you're in a movie but God got a dub dub
and getting pulled over and you start
crying because cops intimidate you so
let's look at the most interesting
examples of how Edgar Wright uses
specific music to construct a scene in
baby driver and spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the movie yet seriously go
watch it okay let's start with the
opening images of the film the music in
this opening heist scene is bell-bottoms
by John Spencer Blues Explosion
[Music]
right actually said this song is what
inspired the old film back in the 90s
when he was 21 and broke he listened to
bell-bottoms and noticed how it starts
out with a steady blues riff and then
two minutes in it explodes into this
frantic garage rock jam he said how this
shift in the music made him visualize an
entire car chase film scene and then
years later in 2011 after Wright made a
few movies that were successful he
directed a music video for mint Royale
called blue song and he said that that
vision in his head transformed into this
concept of a getaway driver waiting
while heist goes down rocking out alone
in a car to the beat of the music with
the song used as a timer for the heist
he actually planned for this music video
to be the opening scene of his eventual
film baby driver and six years later
that's pretty much what he did the first
two minutes of dell bottoms is the timer
for buddy darling and Griff who robbed
the bank and then when they return the
music kick arrives and the chase begins
with each tire screech and police siren
all set to the beat of the music now
this synchronization might have reminded
you of the trailers for Suicide Squad
the way gunfire and punches all
correspond to Bohemian Rhapsody
however right actually said that this is
even more of a challenge in Suicide
Squad trailers work because instead of
an editor just matching up shots to
music in an editing Bay after the fact
he did this process on the set in the
direction of the actors and the stunt
drivers and yeah this is way harder but
right did say it also saved money
because storyboarding each sequence two
sections of a song force them to think
more mathematically because then they're
zero-fat when you're shooting it like
the song won't get any longer so the
stunts have to be exact and stay within
budget okay now let's move on to the
sequence that comes immediately after a
three-minute tracking shot following
Beatty on his morning walk to get coffee
sit to the music of Harlem shuffle by
Bob and Earl
[Music]
they may have noticed that this song
starts the same way as House of Pain
jump around
nothing is how the pain actually sampled
this exact riff from Harlem shuffle and
Wright said that he intentionally wanted
to catch us off-guard like this and he
does it throughout the film using more
obscure covers of songs while in other
cases switching back to the lesser-known
original version Wright also got British
DJ mark Nicholson also known as Ossie me
so to compose a new mix of Harlem
shuffle - whoo blend in audio from
people on the street footsteps people
talking dogs barking and ATM beeping as
woman punches in her pin even the actor
Ansel Elgort saying yeah yeah - the beat
of the music really have to watch this
movie again because even the words and
the signs and the graffiti on the walls
sync up to words that you hear in the
song at that moment the point of all
this is to put us firmly inside baby's
head car accident that he suffered as a
kid left him with a constant rain sound
so he's constantly listening to music to
drown it out so when we go inside his
head we see that the world around him is
alive with music it's as if he's
composing all of these sounds into his
own personal life soundtrack which is
something he literally does later in
this movie now of course this theme was
carefully choreographed ahead of time
Wright brought in the choreographer Ryan
Heffington and he said he walked through
the sequence with an iPhone camera over
and over again to get it precise the end
result is this amazing sequence that
looks like it could be from a musical
like lala land okay let's move on to the
next big action sequence the second
heist in the truck and the music here is
neatly neat by the Damned
[Music]
[Applause]
now Edgar right since the script of the
actors along with the thumb drive
containing the soundtrack and flee from
the Red Hot Chili Peppers who plays
Eddie no nose in the scene solve this
song neatly need in the tracklist and
that is what sealed the deal for him to
be in the film and the fun thing about
the song is that it's too short only
about 2 minutes long so when they were
storyboarding the scene the
cinematographer of the movie bill Pope
told right that they were going to run
out of song these trucks just couldn't
move as fast as right wouldn't need them
to to fit within the song so right said
he came up with a creative solution he
added this shot where they have to
change cards and baby refuses to hit the
gas until he resets the song wait I got
to start the song over Ok Go and this is
great because it also tells us more
about baby as a character he is that
obsessed with having music playing all
the time even if it slows him down for a
second and again this is disciplined by
Edgar Wright insisted so hard on having
this music that he crafted the story and
the character around it and it led to
this great character revealing moment
now we could probably look at the music
in every scene and baby driver like this
like even baby meeting Deborah and the
diner is structured around Carla
Thomas's ba D Y and T Rexes Deborah and
Becks Deborah enter I would love to dig
into those but let's stick with the
action and fast-forward to this
warehouse shootout the music here is
tequila but instead of the popular
champs version that everyone knows right
again use a cover version this one by
the button-down brass now the middle of
this song features a dueling drum solo
and when right first heard that he said
that it would be amazing to do a
gunfight scene to that and because there
was so much gunfire in the scene it
drowned out all the music playing from
the speakers on set or in the earbuds so
the choreographer and stunt guy had to
teach each actor the rhythm of the shot
and then as they repeatedly shot the
scene they had to keep counting them in
like 5 6 7 8 bang bang bang and Wright
said that on one take when he was
checking in with Jamie Foxx to make sure
he had the gunfire rhythm down Fox was
walking him through it saying this guy
goes up about and I go bah bah and then
he jokingly mimed taking a drag on a
cigarette and right love that invisible
cigarette so much that he had Fox do it
for the movie so yeah this is on
another example of this meticulous
choreography to the music
leading to a really fun memorable image
that right probably what I've had in the
film otherwise okay let's take a look at
one last great example of Wright's piece
of music and baby driver later in the
movie the foot chase the music here it's
focused by hocus-pocus god I love saying
[Music]
now Wright said that this was his
favorite part of the movie but that the
studio actually wanted to cut it they
refused to pay for the scene but he
wanted it seemed so bad that he paid out
of pocket for two extra days of shooting
the film now Wright said that he first
heard hocus-pocus on a music show in
England and that he was blown away by
this progressive rock song that unlike
most songs changes tempo throughout the
song now like most songs just have one
tempo that plays all the way through
which isn't really helpful for film
scoring since the action changes so fast
but Wright described focus as the
perfect cardio track that dictates where
baby goes like fast guitars for when
he's sprinting and then this yodeling
section for when he's hiding behind a
tree and then another shift when he's
running through the mall and then an
accordion section when he breaks into a
car now these were just the big examples
of creative music editing that stood out
to me but what was your favorite musical
moment baby drivers also are there any
other movies or TV shows that you think
would have benefited from this approach
of letting music they take the story
really there is so much going on in baby
driver and I would love to do a full
breakdown of all the miserable stuff
that I caught but really just more
people need to go see this movie and you
can help get the word out by sharing
this video
liking it and tweeting with links to
this video and your favorite thing about
baby driver you can hit me up on twitter
directly at EA box or follow new
rockstars on twitter at new rockstars
and of course subscribe to this channel
for all of our videos about film
analysis and music in cinema we've done
this kind of stuff for the Wonder Woman
theme song Game of Thrones and the
soundtrack regarding to the galaxy so
look around I think you'll like a lot of
stuff here and if you really want to be
part of this channel and help us decide
what kind of videos to make you can
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much to all of our current donors
especially Chris quell all of us to you
and your baby driver on the way Congrats
buddy
okay thanks for watching and Edgar
Wright if you're watching this I have a
script that I would love for you to look
at